hi and welcome to another a pack office
hours from the Android developer
relations team your host for today is
going to be right sleep over do you
receive a tank Center hi everybody we
are again excited to have this hangout
we are going to answer questions which
have been posted on moderator by
developers across the world the this
this time we have around 70 questions so
I hang it over to Uncle to take up the
first question uncle over to you thanks
ROG d um so for question number one
which is also first and then take a look
good oh yeah that's that's a good point
yes let's do the introductions so high
I'm I'm Ankur Kotwal and I'm part of the
Android developer relations team and I'm
based in Sydney over you guys hi I'm a
little and I'm baseball hydro book yeah
hi rice tea based out of a triple this
is the Bearskin best in Tokyo okay thank
you so uncle you can start now yeah
we'll have another colleague of ours
joining us shortly Tony Chan who is
based out of Hong Kong okay so question
number one and and we're going off the
the moderator link which is posted on
the the thread so if you have any
questions please please and add them now
we try and give you guys the
opportunities even before hand so as
rows deep says we have a few questions
today and so question number one and I
don't know how to pronounce this but I
think xamarin ported android sauce to c
sharp and they're reporting a huge
performance boost question so it's a
split question does that mean the dalvik
VM is inefficient can I get even better
performance than that using the NDK so
my understanding of what the team at
xamarin has
have achieved is basically allowing you
to develop your apps on C sharp which is
great it's it's quite innovative and
it's good to see more more languages
supported by the community there are of
course always trade-offs if you if you
look at it purely from a performance
point of view and in their purse they
said that it's faster than then
developing for Java in terms of runtime
performance I don't know how accurate
those claims are but assuming they are
but that's one way to look at it the
other way that I guess you should look
at it is how the developer tools are you
going to be as productive using those
sets of developer tools as opposed to
what you have today with the combination
of Eclipse and Java or IntelliJ in Java
so it's more than just performance I
mean if we were looking purely from a
performance point of view you know ndk
gives tons of performance because you're
building your writing in c and but you
know the developer productivity is not
not as as high so it's great to see that
you know c sharp or mono is a is an
alternative for Android and I i think
our advice is basically pick the tool
that suits you best okay cool uncle up
so yeah so Tony also has joined us who
stood who is everyone yeah Tywin and so
what next question is about c2dm
messaging and a lot so I will hand it
over tornado right the question is now
when the client login authentication is
deprecated should be used over two point
oh four c2dm messaging would be great if
you have an example here to get not
token with or to use with c2dm messaging
so the answer to this is yes we know
c2dm is is being deprecated and
scrubbing out the best way to
authenticate but for now that's the only
solution we have its you see to it is to
use crime log in to get the tokens
required for pushing your messages but
we
also working on a better more robust
authentication model but for now that's
that's the way where you have is a
flight log also note that in this case
you are not using users credential
because the user is already
authenticated on the phone it's the
developer who's using the security I'm
account credentials to get the token for
pushing a message cool thanks Andrew
next question is again for me on this is
on graphic you I editor so the question
is last week my question was announced
was answered advising me not to use the
graphic you I editor because of bugs
which made me think how is the workflow
like with UI designers on the team
should I just ask the designer to draw
the UI then I reproduced in on XML so
the first thing is probably this
question was not the was asking the
North America hang out ours or the MEI
not ask because we can have this in a
fact but anyway we will try to answer
your question so yes there are so much
with the GUI editor but if you need
rapid prototyping me advise you to use
some special tools available this
there's one set of tools available with
Android UI utils which also includes the
icon generator and stuff they're not
some stencils boots there so you can use
these tools with your designers to come
up with rapid prototypes for your
applications we can then convert to a
given application code let's see let's
see only where we can advise you right
okay thanks everyone yeah I will it's
kind of tricky to a bit of a very nice
UI with the tools we have but again you
always have the option of going back to
eczema if you feel that you know you're
losing control by using the UI okay so
next question is on emulators support
for high resolution so i am going to
take up the question does the emulator
support high resolution and density from
the newest devices smartphones and
tablets so they're not as a question
there is a comment
configure the emulator with the high
resolution and ICS target emulator just
shows a black screen or hands up okay so
first I'll answer the first part so when
you create a DVD there is a default
abstract density which is set so for a
VDS which are targeted for 4.0 dot 4 or
4.0 dot 3 the affected density is 240
DPA and and if you are creating a VD for
Honeycomb which is 3.1 or 3.2 the app
circuit density is around 160 and for
the winner a VD sits around 240 again so
because tablets typically have a lower
densities and you can also change the
density by editing by VD so to answer
your question the yes you can abstract a
given density or change the density when
you create any VD now why is this not
happening in your particular EVD it's
difficult to answer that question
without getting more information from
you in terms of what did you try to
change the abstract density density or
were you trying to change the screen
size in terms of pixels and if there is
a way you can provide us that
information then you know we might be
able to answer that in more detail so
uncle is there a channel where
developers can come back and ask them
and provide more detail about the
questions it was a good question what I
suggest is either reach out to to us on
g+ any of us that are that have joined
the hangout or just follow up in you
know in another moderated question for
next week's hang out whatever suits the
person yeah yeah yeah maybe another
follow-up question next week in the
meantime you can either send your
comments directly to me on my G+ account
dot one two or two and your parts but
the answer to the first part is yes you
can this is abstract a density density
which you can change a fruity or require
so moving on to the next question I let
Roy's okay take this up Japan so the
next question is not a question but the
suggestion please up entry to the money
have to fire automatically for every new
activity class created yeah I think this
is an interesting suggestion and stuff
the I understand your pain of that see
you have to basically manually enter
manifests tag every time you create
activity like the 10 x 20 x you pretty
much type same thing than 10 x 20 time
so let me take this as a feature request
for our tooth team and then let's see
how it goes thank you for solution oh I
would just like to add something the
there is a side by the Android the two
steam if you just search for android the
boots project you crack that beautiful
search is done we do have an issue
tracker there and the engineers out
there so if you can directly if you want
to directly follow up with the
engineering team on there is a request
there and they should cracker you can do
that yeah good cool thank you rice okay
Tony you want to add something yeah so
I'll take the next question so the
question was thanks for answering my
question last week when I enable gps
aeration in the emulator the emulator
just show a flat screen and didn't run
is there highway requirement on the GPS
l on to Pilar celebration so um I guess
my question that you would be all which
graphic card are you using and also
which platform are you want so seems
like something are specific to your to
your to your environment I will suggest
you to arm sense or either either
contact me on G+ or two so we can work
offline to to find out what kind of
exactly the problem you have so
um seems like it's pretty specific so
maybe you can you can send me a perfect
or g + r pose look forward to that okay
cool thanks so the next question I'll
try to answer this is on storing your
login credentials locate ok for my app I
need user log in each time as it is Dean
sensitive data how do you suggest I
store the earth data application
contains seems to be a bad way of
showing it ok of course
applicationcontext it gets killed by
process manager your application context
data is lost so I think there are one or
two approaches the best approaches not
to store the passwords directly locally
what you should do is you should become
a provider on the server side and you
should store the OAuth access token on
the client side and and the best way to
store it is in shared preferences so
that even if your app is our activity is
destroyed and when it's created again
you can note those that access token
from the sheer preferences and so that
you are already logged in and you don't
have to go through that flow again I
think that is a easy and sweet answer to
this question so next question at hand
it over to later the question is I'm
having trouble with t2dm and the
receiving phone is in sleep mode video
from google i/o suggests that we should
implement a heartbeat mechanism this is
the latin mean increments something to
wake up the phone and perform something
in HTTP so I think the heartbeat
mechanism they're being taught us about
to keep the connection in life you have
some personal going on but you can
periodically wake up the system using a
la manager but we would just advise you
not to be took really here or do that
too often also you don't need to perform
an HTTP request to get the network the
c2dm notifications
it's just to wake up the system also i
think the second part the heartbeat part
is if you actually have a non-trivial
task a long-running trance cuban when
the intent broadcast system makes up
your your application will censor
message to your application what you
want to do there is use the acquirer
wake up to actually dispatched your
processing to a service if it's a
non-trivial non-running operation and
there that's 21 probably use a HTTP keep
a license and see you next question is
for Tony yeah so the question here was
we bill Android 4.3 tablets with our
Bluetooth module building we want to use
a bluetooth USB adapter instead we need
bluetooth install in the system menu
petition so this is working on a 2.3 is
it possible in android for so i guess
like dis questions since you are
building your own hardware i guess um my
understanding is in android for we do
support accessory so usps accessory api
definitely you can have your tablet as a
USB hose as well as a slave um and in
terms of whether our hardware with ada
issue because this is a this is a
discussion or hangout for discussing on
api related questions we're not expert
in hardware so i would suggest you to go
to a couple of these discussion
discussion groups or that may you may be
may be able to find answer one of them
would be android ash platforms in Google
Groups another one would be Android ash
porting so arms most likely you can find
some good answer from the comment
through the community there so thank you
ok cool so next question from uncle job
in India it's on map support
fragrance again Tony would be like
transferred for our fragments so this is
one of the very popular feature requests
we have we understand we currently don't
have a firm in support for maps and
currently we don't have any announcement
but our engineering team are aware of
the issues and looking into it so um so
sorry for now yeah yeah I think we keep
getting this in every second handled and
so it's a question which is very popular
so next question is on android market
for in donation programmers voice okay
okay the question is okay from
international program er when we can use
it to make money because ordinal have
serves the program okay so this question
is about okay d nokia windows solve that
problem but the Indonesian programmer
still doesn't have google play the
answer is yeah i understand you really
feel frustrated about the lack of the
paid application support and in-app
billing support in indonesia and the
only answer I can give you right now is
that we are always working on extending
Google Play paid applications and in-app
billing support to more and more
countries and unfortunately we don't
have any specific timeline I can tell
right now and but the pretty pretty
quickly aware that we are definitely
working on that thank you very much okay
thanks Royce okay next question again
from Indonesia this looks more like a
user feature requests make a picture to
back up our SMS message
so gmail integrated with the android
messaging app and not a third party here
okay this is not a developer question
but looks like a user require feature
request for the gmail android ah so what
we do is we give this feedback to the
specific team which is building this up
and it will be up to them and the PM put
aside I know and evaluate this feature
but thanks for giving the suggestion and
so I think we move on to the next
question quickly over to you on it okay
the question is any plans of getting
android 4.4 galaxy nexus 2 in Game
Developers bringing nearly six months
now so unfortunately we do not know if
any such plans you're not aware so maybe
I think the good thing would be to
follow up with samsung india but then I
product out their website or with their
various social channels to figure out
their launch pads we don't have any
information that okay cool thanks a
health yeah there was one presley's
which Sampson did around this maybe you
want to check that I don't remember the
condensed but they had said something
about this particular launch but i think
samsung india and their PR department
would be the right channel to ask this
question next question is on one of the
legal matter so I mean hand it over to
Uncle ah thanks Raj zip so the question
is according to the jury and there's
some references to the case going on
between Oracle and Google and basically
look none of us on this on this call our
lawyers we were not supposed to talk
about litigation and so we don't have an
answer for this it's it's certainly
outside of the scope of of this hang-up
or so
thanks for the question but you probably
need to find a different audience for it
yeah thanks uncle the next person is
again for you oh yeah so the question is
how can I move all my android apps to
the SD card now um I I think that this
person is asking a developer question
but you could frame this question either
way so basically from a developer's
point of view you can you can specify in
your manifest file that your app can be
moved to the SD card and there's
basically a parameter that you can add
the other parameter you can add is you
can set the default install location
yeah and you can basically say hey it's
always installed to the SD card so i
guess that's that's how you can do it
for your your your apps themselves if
you're looking at it from a user's point
of view look developers have to enable
the option to move to SD card it's not
something that you can blankly just go
and say move all my apps to the SD card
now you might also ask well why is that
not the default and basically SD cards
you can think of them as transient
storage because people can eject the SD
card switch it out with another SD card
or just not have an SD card in the
device so it's not something that
developers should be assuming will
always be present you can run into some
funny issues there as well because if
you've got an app that for example has a
widget or has a service it will not work
that widget basically won't work on the
if the user adds it to the launcher what
will typically happen is that the user
will be able to add that widget to the
launcher and next time they reboot their
device that widget will probably
disappear or you'll have some sort of
error shown there and and that has to do
with you know the boot order in
and how quickly the SD card can get
mounted it on so forth so look we
understand that move to SD s SD card is
the feature that you might find
attractive you have to be very careful
how you use it though so i would suggest
try and sort of see if you can split
your app up in some some clever ways
such that you've got your your core rap
is nice and small and the data part of
your app is maybe using our a new
extension apks so that we can separate
out the you know where it's stored and
so on okay thanks ogre Oh next question
is on a Google Play and rice okay you
won't take it it's from noida india okay
thank you ready deep and the question is
google play the unload through default
web browser HTC Sense doesn't watch on
Wi-Fi proxy server do something about
this okay this is a probably not really
question probably more about three
charities about supporting Wi-Fi proxy
server in EG evasion and that the thank
you for your suggestion and that I
direct to mention that the under the
team continues working on improving
enterprise features of Android devices
for example in Ice Cream Sandwich under
a four point all we have done a bunch of
things so that you can use android phone
inside cooperator network and but the
there are certain steps you should
follow in order that you can use your
device inside corporate network but
these it's definitely becoming easier
and Aditya I direct to suggest that you
would take a look into how you would be
able to use your network your private
network with your under the device using
some booty and computer
and then you would be able to use your
private Wi-Fi network together with the
under the device and the otherwise we
also continue working on making it
easier for you jerk consumers to
configure networks like the probe using
proxy servers but I understand that this
is not always simple process so thank
you for suggestion and let us continue
working on this thank you cool thanks
Royce ok so we have tried to answer all
the questions which were posted on
moderator and very soon we'll be sharing
the the video of this session uncle
would you like to add yeah we actually
have a couple questions that have come
in a little bit late so let's answer
those we also have our sutton on the on
the thread who mentioned that he's
posted a link saying that samsung india
said there is a definite no to galaxy
nexus in india and he's posted a link to
an article issue i'm assuming that that
article is is accurate but people can
have a look so we have two questions
that have come through one of them is
from someone called Thomas and I'm sorry
Tomas if I mispronounce your name the
question is and I guess I nearer than
right did this one's for you is what are
the specifics of the Indian Play Store I
have an app that is very successful in
Asia but almost no sales in India is a
judo translation or is it due to the
cost of the app ok so I'm assuming he's
referring to the paid apps right I
assume so because he's talking about the
price of a nap ok o Yaran up see
different markets
respond differently to paid apps but we
have not released any stocks which are
specific to a particular market so we
can't really comment on you know how
paid apps are doing in India vs. all
they're doing it somewhere else so you
want yeah I think I think it'd be nice
if you could check your publisher stats
and see like where your downloads are
coming away or in stores are coming from
is it just a paid app or is it the
freemium model you see downloads for
like your free app and then not not so
much for the paid apps it would be
interesting to see if we actually have
users who are using a free apple Indian
not choosing to buy the beta version in
that case maybe you can work through a
different model yeah yeah I would also
add that and this and this response
isn't specific to India but generally
apps do vary in terms of how they
perform in different markets you know
different cultures different religions
different languages they have different
tastes so an app that might be high
quality may be popular in let's say
Japan but not so popular in Australia
because of the type of content it has or
just the style around it so without
knowing too much about what app you're
referring to oh and what your target
market is it's really hard to comment
but i would have a look at just seeing
whether there is anything in the way
that that app is presented whether there
is something that's called that it's
referring to that something culturally
sensitive or otherwise you know what
what differences may lie yeah and
sometimes even translations you ask the
question about translation it depends I
mean generally if it's an app that's
written in English you know English is a
very dominant language in India but
obviously you could you could still
translate it and get a broader user base
in within India as well yo I would also
like to add that it depends on how
various markets they respond to a beta
so as an adult said you might want to
explore other options like freemium
model where you start with the free
version and
paid adults that model might work better
in India as compared to some of the
repair countries yeah and we also have
one other question and it's actually a
really interesting question basically
red stool on the thread is asking that
if you have an app on the market that
that's kind of distributed or split up
such that you've got like am a nap and
then you've got a bunch of sort of
add-ons or plugins for that app then the
issue that he's seeing is that he's
saying that main app needs to request
every permission where you know where as
that permission might only be required
for the for the plug-in itself now
wrestle that's a very interesting
question this is a topic that I've
discussed with developers in the past
and there are ways to actually make it
such that your main app does not require
the permissions that your ad on does so
examples of that are basically if you
can split your app up such that it's
it's a standalone service so I don't
know just to throw it out there maybe
you have an add-on that allows you to
import contacts or export context that
add-on itself that deals with contacts
if you have that is like a service
component which you can then invoke from
your main app using some you know an API
that you determine you can ensure that
your main app doesn't require the SMS
sorry not SMS contact read and write
permission so it depends how you break
it up but there's certainly ways to
achieve what you're after now
unfortunately Rasool wasn't able to join
us on the Hangout itself so I don't know
whether he's got any follow-up questions
I guess in the meantime that's that's a
wrap for today right rajdeep yeah yeah
so thanks for posting all these
questions we have tried our best to
answer them
based on our knowledge and if you have
any additional questions you cannot ask
them in the next version of the hangout
or you can also pick us off line if you
have any specific discussion I cannot
the question you already us so I guess
we can wrap up this version of the dev
handle for Android developers alright
thanks for joining everyone see you
later bye